today we had the last meeting of the
Health Minister ministers during the
Estonian presidency and glad that we
reached an agreement on several
important issues that will help
accelerate digital innovation in
healthcare and take steps
towards protecting the health of our
people more efficiently that is we
agreed on the council conclusions on
health and also on the cross-border
aspects of alcohol policy and
we also had a
vocal discussion about the state of play
in the future of European
pharmaceuticals policy adopted
conclusions emphasized the potential of
digital technologies and advanced data
analytics in contributing to more
empowered citizens better targeted more
integrated and safer healthcare and
consequently also more efficient use of
healthcare resources I'm also pleased
that today the council adopted
conclusions on cross-border aspects of
alcohol and fully supporting member
states efforts to reduce our consumption
abuse and the harm that it causes our
shared target is to reduce alcohol
related harm by 10 percent we need to
monitor regularly the progress made I
welcome that the conclusion stressin
need to address alcohol across policies
and call once again on member states to
enshrine alcohol concerns into pricing
marketing and selling arrangements this
instruments are in the hands of member
states and I have once more urged
ministers to do everything in their
power to use them as much as possible to
the benefit of Public Health